(audience cheering)
- Welcome back.
Tomorrow's national STEM Day.
A time to encourage
kids, especially girls,
to explore science, technology,
engineering, and math.
The truth is, women are
grossly underrepresented
in STEM fields.
We make up half the US
workforce, but only 27%
of STEM workers.
But we are making progress, y'all.
50 years ago it was only 8%.
So (excited chant) back
with another STEM experiment
you can try at home is
Philip Cook, better known
as Chem Teacher Phil, give it up.
(audience cheering)
Great to see you again.
- Great to see you as well.
Thanks for having me.
- Absolutely love you.
Okay, so why is STEM so
important for all kids?
- I think we want the
best for our kids, right?
We want to prepare them for
what they're going to see
in their life ahead
when they become adults.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think for them, they
need to be problem solvers
and critical thinkers.
So STEM activities that we can do
with them at an early
age help set the stage
for them to be successful.
- Promotes that. Yeah, that
foundation. I like that.
So wait, what are we
learning today? I'm stoked.
- So today we're going to
be do doing an experiment.
It's all about the S in STEM.
- Okay.
- We're gonna be doing
a science experiment.
- Okay.
- And it's a pretty
simple experiment that you
guys can do at home as
well to celebrate tomorrow
which is gonna be national STEM day.
- [Kelly] That's true.
- And you just need three things.
So you're gonna need
a microwave like this.
You'll need some paper, which
we've got paper up here.
And a pilot friction pen which has special
thermo-sensitive ink.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
The go-to eraseable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show".
Is that what we were talking about?
Is that what you're talking about?
(audience clapping)
They're great pens.
How do we... No, I actually love
- They're the go-to pen in my class too.
My kids love them.
- [Kelly] I actually love them.
We're so stoked to partner.
So how do we use them in the experiment?
- So what we're gonna be
doing is an experiment
where we learn about microwaves,
like how a microwave works.
So we're gonna be using the ink
which will disappear when it's heated
to be able to tell us where it's hot
and where it's not in a microwave.
Because believe it or not
microwaves don't do the best
job of evenly heating foods.
You will know this if you've
ever had a frozen burrito
and you stick it in the microwave
and one part's frozen
and the other part's like molten lava.
- This is like my
childhood with hot pockets.
- [Phil] Yeah
- Yeah.
- [Phil] Absolutely. Absolutely.
- You burn your tongue
on the outside and then
in the middle. I'm like,
how is this still ice?
I don't know.
Yeah.
- But one of your stage hands, Marcel.
- [Kelly] Marcel, he's
- [Phil] Made a great picture for us.
- He's so talented.
- Yeah. Look at that.
- I love that he made angry Blake.
(audience clapping)
- So he used pilot friction pens for this.
So what we're gonna see,
hopefully is wherever
this part of the paper gets
hot, the thermo sensitive ink
is going to disappear.
And we're just gonna see
what that looks like.
- Okay. Marcel, you're so gifted.
God, you can draw so well.
We saw him on K, yeah, he's incredible.
Okay, so we're putting it in there.
- [Phil] Yeah.
- Okay.
- And it doesn't take long.
So when you're doing this at home, just
- Okay.
- You wanna take the tray out.
We've already done that.
- I kind of noticed that.
And I was like, are you missing something?
But okay that was on purpose.
- You don't move or else you kind of ruin.
- [Kelly] Oh, I get
it. I get it. I get it.
Let's see how much of Blake is left.
- Prediction?
- How to make Blake disappear.
I've been working on this
experiment for years.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, here we go.
- Oh my gosh.
(audience clapping)
- He's just a head of hair.
- Yeah. So here's what's
interesting about that.
You can see there's some
spots where there's still
clearly ink.
That's where it didn't get hot enough.
And if you think about it like this
you see hot spot, cold
spot, hot spot, cold spot.
Well if you know that a
microwave is a wave kind
of goes like this.
The high part of the wave
and the low part of the wave,
those are what make the molecules
in food like the fat,
the protein, the water,
and the jiggle.
And when they kind of
hit against one another
that translates into heat.
So here they got hot. Here they were not.
- I love that.
Okay.
- But now this is without the tray.
So now we can actually see
why it has to be in there.
So we're gonna take this part out.
- So, we're taking that. Okay.
- And we're going to put the tray back in
and see why most microwave
ovens have to have
something that rotates the food.
- Are we making him completely disappear?
This is the best magic ever.
- No spoilers.
We'll let it go for about 10 or 15.
Well, I set it for 20, but we
- We might take it out? Okay.
- Yeah. What do you think's gonna happen?
- In my heart?
- Yeah.
- I think he's just gonna be gone.
- All of him?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
And then I'm gonna send it to him.
(laughing)
- But, okay. Wait, there's something else
that's cool about this ink.
You can cool it down and
make the ink come back.
I'll show you that here in
- Who needs to do that?
I'm just kidding.
- Now if you look
- Oh my gosh.
- A lot more of it's gone.
- Can we talk about that two
pages hanging on right now?
Like, that's like, that's crazy.
- So this is the reason
why when you're using
a microwave that you
wanna make sure the food's
on the edges.
So if you put a plate of spaghetti in here
it's gonna be nice and warmed up here.
But right here near the toupee.
That's where it's gonna be icy cold.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah.
- Okay. How do you make it?
Are you gonna make it come back?
- [Phil] I think we should.
- Okay.
- So it relies upon temperature.
Hot to make it disappear.
We're gonna make it really cold.
Now, if you're at home and
you try this experiment
you could try it by just sticking
in the freezer for a little bit.
And the coldness of the freezer
will make the ink come back.
But we're gonna use
- Oh, I need glasses.
- Cause I'm a chemistry teacher
we're gonna use something
a little bit more intense.
- This is where we look really hot, man.
This is where it turn
on America right now.
- [Phil] This is right.
- Hi.
Pilot Friction eraseable go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
(audience laughing)
- So got some dry ice in here.
Solid carbon dioxide
which is really cold
about negative 79 Celsius.
Negative 110 Fahrenheit.
- [Kelly] I knew that.
I was just making sure you did.
- It was a quiz.
So we're just gonna dump some.
Try not get you with it.
On top of Blake.
And we're gonna let sit for a second.
- We're dumping on Blake.
Okay. (laughing) This
is the greatest episode.
It does start to come back.
- It's starting to come back.
So we see him starting to come back
and then normally we use
our hand and warm it up.
- [Kelly] He's all happy
playing guitar again.
Look at that.
- Back to normal.
- [Kelly] God's country back.
There you go.
Thank you so much, Chem Teacher.
This is so cool.
I love science.
It is cool.
Yeah. Be sure to follow him
on TikTok @chemteacherphil.
And check out kellyclarksonshow.com.
for more friction...